hi how come I have visions of another
life please make them stop
is that what you really want to make the
vision
stop what do you want the true yes the
skin the house we've been finding around
the city the ones we think are attached
to the metahumans this is now the fourth
one well let's figure out what's
happening before there's a fifth just
who are you I am alchemy okay well what
do you want to help people achieve their
full potential such as he yes why are
you doing this because I'm preparing hey
youtubers it's Charlie this is just
gonna be a deep dive into Doctor
Alchemy's character from the flash
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
episode 2 yet we'll be talking about
episode 2 stuff so here we go so let's
go over to the things that the TV show
is done with the character so far just
like based on the evidence that they've
given us we know that he has an
underground lair
just like comic book doctor alchemy he's
trying to help everyone achieve their
true potential that's like a slightly
different version of him from the comics
the comic book version of the character
was a more common criminal someone named
Albert Desmond who was interested in
chemistry but found out about the
Philosopher's Stone so it was also
called the alchemists stuff like the
Philosopher's Stone is what it was
called for most of the comics so we'll
just refer to it as the Philosopher's
Stone he eventually decides to stop
being a criminal and stop using the
Philosopher's Stone but then another
identical person pops up named Alvin
Desmond it turns out that there's an
evil twin later in the comics they
retcon that and it ends up being a
projection of the Philosopher's Stone
so like the stone itself created an evil
duplicate of him so eventually Albert
defeated Alvin and reassumed the mantle
of dr. alchemy the Philosopher's Stone
itself just allows him to transmute
matter into anything else he has a
psychic link with the stone so he can
control it from a distance he doesn't
have to be holding it but that's the
first version of dr. alchemy the Albert
Desmond the second version is called
Alexander Petrov he was created by Geoff
Johns it actually worked inside the
crime lab with Barry now he was called
mr. element so there have been versions
of dr. alchemy that have gone back and
forth between those names like one
version of dr. alchemy used the name mr.
element the other used the name dr.
alchemy so the second version of the
character didn't start out as a villain
eventually grew to hate Barry Allen and
took up the mantle of mr. element and
used something called the element gun
that allowed him to change the structure
of elements he wore a mask that looks
kind of like TV show dr. Alchemy's mask
so what it seems like is going on is
they're combining the first version of
the character and the second version of
the character in the comics because I do
think that tom Felton is deeply linked
to the dr. alchemy character he's a
metahuman specialist dr. alchemy has a
particular interest in helping
metahumans realize their full potential
so when he finds a person who was a
metahuman during flashpoint likes a
killer frost or say Wally he wants to
help them achieve their true potential
to prepare the earth we still don't know
what he's preparing the earth for and we
haven't met savatage yet but they're
just a couple twists that the flash
could be borrowing from the comics now
like when they did Jay Garrick he ended
up being hunter zolomon that was just
using the name Jay Garrick and he was
oom so hunter zolomon was zoom so they
were true to that origin in the comics
even though they changed some details
about his backstory so what I think
they're doing is is they are doing like
a version of the Albert Desmond doctor
alchemy but they're kind of mixing and
matching some of his backstory elements
but they're relatively true to the name
itself so the twist I'm expecting is and
like the way they've set up the Julianne
Albert character is that he's a totally
normal person who's very good at his job
he has a particular interest in
metahuman so he has a really sharp mind
and everybody likes him so in his speech
to Barry you know he says he doesn't
trust him so he doesn't like him I don't
like people that I don't trust
I think the twist here is this that he
will actually be exactly what you see
but he will be linked you know via a
twist to dr alchemy who is tom Felton
also but a different character so dr.
alchemy Theory number one is that tom
Felton is playing both dr. alchemy who's
a different character from the Julianne
Albert character so you're doing like an
Albert Desmond thing but Alvin Desmond
is the evil persona that's wearing the
dr. alchemy mask because like the way
they charted the timeline of the episode
unless
Julian Albert is like the only doctor
alchemy and is using mirror master to
travel around the city really really
fast then Julian in dr. alchemy are two
different people I do kind of feel like
they're two different people I just
think that Julian Albert isn't aware of
the dr. alchemy persona so you have this
situation whereby he could be a split
personality or he could be a psychic
twin via the Philosopher's Stone in like
all this fracturing time that was caused
by very I do think that Barry's actions
directly led to the creation of dr.
alchemy but we don't really know a lot
about the Philosopher's Stone in how
it's tied to fracturing time in
unlocking people's potential like sort
of combining them with their alternate
universe selves like okay this version
of you and another timeline in
flashpoint had powers how do we
overwrite that on the current copy
that's the thing we haven't seen yet
we'll probably get to see that in a
future episode so we'll learn how the
Philosopher's Stone is involved with
that it probably has something to do
with this underground temple in this
obelisk here which makes you think
abouts avatar like okay Sabbat are had
an obelisk like that in his castle so
either he is working together with
alchemy because I do kind of feel like
this metal hand here is Savitt are now
so either he's working force avatar or
sabotage working for dr. alchemy but
just because dr. alchemy speaks with
Tobin bells voice don't automatically
assume that he's an old man that that's
why I think it's a bit of a misdirect
with the tom felton so let me know in
the comments do you think that dr.
alchemy is being played by tom felton as
like an alternate universe version or an
alternate personality like the albert
alvin desmond from the comics I just
feel like what's gonna happen by the end
of the season is is that tom Felton will
continue to be a really big character I
mean he's a lot of fun he was actually
really good in all the scenes we saw him
in so can't wait to see more from him
even though he seems abrasive I think
we'll find out that he's not a bad
person and they'll try to save him while
getting rid of dr. alchemy it's just
that I don't think that this character
that tom Felton is playing Albert
Desmond is the actual villain I think
he's exactly what you see dr. alchemy
is something completely different even
though I think he's also going to be tom
felton when you rip the mask off so they
are doing a lot of comic book stuff but
they do like to have fun with the way
they do backstory so just expect some
changes from dr. alchemy comic book
backstory but give me all your dr.
alchemy theories in the comments I just
I feel like they're combining a couple
versions of the character but the big
twist is something from classic Albert
Alvin Desmond dr. alchemy so new episode
of arrow tonight they're debuting the
Artemis character as well as the rest of
the new team Oliver is basically gonna
be kicking the [ __ ] out of them like the
drill sergeant from Full Metal Jacket so
I'll post that video after the episode
airs be sure to subscribe to get it
there is a new round of the giveaway
that's going on right now the DC
giveaway and there was a new episode of
agents of shield I don't know if I'm
gonna do a video for it but I do need to
wrap up the rest of my Luke Cage so I
might talk about Ghost Rider stuff in
that Luke Cage video because they did
confirm a few Ghost Rider comic book
things and they finally revealed what
Mira is going to look like in the
Aquaman movie in Justice League she'll
be like a small part of Justice League
like very very small but obviously a big
big part of the Aquaman movie so I'll do
the video for that after I do arrow so
that'll post tomorrow morning well you
guys wait at the post you can click here
for my flash episode 2 video and you can
click here for that justice league
behind the scenes trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight